il m'entraîne au bout de la nuit les
démons de minuit mais aussi confidence
pour confidence ou encore born to be
alive et des tubes qui ont marqué les
années 80 et qui sont aujourd'hui
devenus des incontournables plébiscité
par le public
en témoigne l'accueil réservé au
chanteur devenu acteur lors de l'avant
première de star 80 à juger ces deux
meetings le bretonneux mardi sud
j'étais plutôt habitué à rentrer dans
des salles feutrées des gens concentrer
sur un film avec parfois quelqu'un qui
fait du bruit en toussant ou en mangeant
des chips biscuits des trente ans
immédiatement champ alors là je suis le
mec est pas debout sur son côté il passe
pour un star 80 où l'histoire de deux
copains qu'il essayait d'organiser une
tournée à travers la france avec les
gloires passées du top 50
enfin de nous la star des années 80 avec
emile et images pittoresques loti début
de soirée jean pierre mader sabrina bio
cookie dingler jean luc lahaye jeanne
mas
gilbert montagné elle se tait raid
s'était ainsi qu'à c'est super je suis
très ma part que même pas mon nom reciva
regarde et cetera c'est par un concert
filmé c'est pas un karaoké parce que sa
critique parce que par ok c'est pas un
concert filmé c'est pas une télévision
sur grand écran
non c'est un hommage s'est passé à ces
gens là
à cette période à ce qu'ils ont parce
qu'ils ont installés pour très longtemps
dans la mémoire collective dans la
mémoire d'homme dans la culture
française en fin de la chanson française
t'inquiète pas à temps je passe super
bien qu'est ce qui a motivé votre retour
d'immostar sommes réglées au pluriel
ses caprices de star fermin 20 de toute
façon c'est pas vous les stars c'est vos
chansons voilà personne connaît leur
prénom c'est quoi vos prénoms en tic et
tac début et soirée n'importe qui peut
chanter vos chansons extra franchement
extra le fait de revoir les tuer tous
adhéré entendre sa move ça fait du bien
c'est un truc de fou star 80 à la fiche
depuis ce 24 octobre plusieurs millions
de spectateurs sont attendus
elle viendra ensuite le temps pour les
chanteurs de repartir sur scène
déclinaison du film projeté en salle le
spectacle de la troupe reprendra la
route début 2013